physical competency skills this is a
very very basic one you know for being
honest like anybody can achieve this I
get there's some people are going to
struggle like how do I you know how do I
go and get this job or how do I lean
into this if I already got all these
debts or they've already got me Slave to
the Grind like those are the common
complaints right is like how do I go and
make that money okay what's stopping you
from getting up in the morning getting
out of bed and doing 20 push-ups can't
do 20 do 15 can't do 15 do 10 can't do
one on the ground stand up against the
wall and do a wall
pushup don't tell me that you can't
Embrace physical competency okay
building a strong masculine frame can
you fight do you know how to fight
serious question right because for
decades I spent a lot of time going to
the gym picking up heavy [__] putting it
down building very physically strong
masculine body uh low body fat broad
shoulders and arrow waist and then it
dawned on me one day I was like how the
hell do I defend myself I a fight CU I'm
I'm not traveling like I've got money to
travel weird places some oddl looking
characters that you have to size up
depending on the time of day depending
on the part of the city you're in
depending on who you're with and what
you know about where you're at and it da
me how do I how do I handle a situation
like that because people will typically
just leave you alone if you're big
strong and imposing looking that's the
benefit to it that's that's one of the
first benefits is people just leave you
the [__] alone right they don't want to
get into an Ultra or fight with you if
you look like you can [__] [__] up
physical competency skills go beyond
just looking a certain part obviously
being strong being healthy living in a
physically strong body I still to this
day go down through all these different
kinds of rabbit holes let me show you
something I've been working on real
quick hold on I think I'm going to
document this separately on my other
channel but there's this there's this
MRT uh test that I did a few weeks ago
it's called the mediator release test
and it's the most complete blood test
for food and food chemical sensitivities
and I put together like this is how
geeky that I go down these rabbit holes
when it comes to physical competency I
want to get rid of as much inflammation
in my body as possible so I've had my
blood pulls a$1 th000 test I'm gonna
tell you guys in the next three weeks
exactly what kind of results I got out
of running this I'll be straight up
forward I'll tell you exactly what I get
out of this this is how down in the
weeds that I get but I'm talking about
basic physical competency skills you
should like honestly guys today
if if you're a teenager or older 16 17
year old like 16 year old if you're a
16year old man and older you should be
able to do 100 push-ups over the course
of about 15 20 minutes I'm not saying
you got to do 100 straight but do 20
take a break for a few minutes do 20
like do that five times you've got 100
push-ups you would not be surprised
sorry you would be surprised at the
amount of men that can't even come close
to that it you know it's a a simple task
of of physical strength beyond that once
you've got physical strength then you
can use it you can deploy it in certain
areas right um got to move heavy [__]
around your house you want to jack up a
car and change a a tire you know a tire
on a rim if you're swapping out Summers
for Winters is a basic skill you know
for being honest it's a physical
competency skill but that sort of thing
might weigh 45 or 50 pounds there's a
lot of people out there if they un
unbolted them I mean most people don't
even know how to change a freaking tire
but if they unbolted them they would
have difficulty pulling it off getting
it off they wouldn't know how to shim it
off right these are just basic things so
learn how to fight be able to to do
basic physical challenges squats you
know you should be able to squat your
body weight you should be able to bench
press your body weight from reps um I'm
in a signal chat with a few of my boys
and just for shits and giggles we
started calling each other out oh so and
so can't do this you can't do that so we
started posting videos of ourselves
doing body weight for reps right um I'm
about to 15 I mean I did 225s on the bar
which is 245s and I probably punched out
like eight or nine right like you should
be able to do that and I'm not a young
man I'm not a spring chicken okay I've
been around for a while you should be
able to do these things if I can do it
there's absolutely no reason why you
can't do it and then last thing when it
comes to the physical part is a 1.62
golden ratio there's absolutely no
freaking reason why you should be
walking around fat it's it's inexcusable
it's unnecessary it slows you down it
closes doors for you it it reduces
options in all areas of life not just
women but get it sorted out and it's
really easy to do um got a I don't have
a proper tape measure here but just find
something that you can write on with a
uh dry erase marker stand up against
your glass shower door uh stainless
steel refrigerator something that's you
know wide enough that you can mark on
either side and all you do is you take a
dry erase marker mark your shoulder
and then the shoulder up against it and
you mark your waist the this side of the
waist then you take your measurement and
then you divide the short part into the
wide part and if your ratio is 1.62 or
better you're good if you're talking one
to one like your waist is as wide as
your shoulders because you got an nrow
shoulders and a wide waist you have work
to do there's like playing video games
and [__] around and you know surfing
the internet or looking at only fans or
whatever it is that dorks are doing that
are that are stopping them from getting
serious about making bank and taking
their physicality serious I'll tell you
right now I I have I have zero [__]
tolerance for anybody that shows up at
one of my events out of shape they will
hear about it they will [__] hear
about it the whole [__] event from me
and they will do something about it if
they're going to stick around otherwise
they're out okay physical competency
skills understand and own the basic
shouldn't be that hard uh chinups are
another really simple measurement right
um you should be able to lift your body
weight up multiple times seven eight 10
times would be ideal 10 or more is great
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out